well many MPS will be looking forward to
president zielinski's address to
Parliament this afternoon but first the
normal duties of the day originally has
to get through pmqs he's only got six
minutes to get from number 10 down to
the House of Commons I will bring you
the images when he does leave but first
of all I'm joined in the studio by rmp's
panel for the conservatives we have
Theresa villier's former cabinet
minister for labor Stephen Morgan and
the shadow Minister for schools for and
also for the liberal Democrats we've got
Alastair Carmichael who's the party's
home Affairs for justice and Northern
Ireland spokesperson as well Teresa
Villas to you first of all we were going
to talk very in detail really about the
cabinet reshuffle yesterday but but
first what about this visit today how
significant is it do you feel I think
it's a hugely significant reminder of
the you know the traumas being suffered
by Ukraine and I think we can be proud
that as a country and as a government
we've been foremost in providing Lethal
Weapon support for Ukraine and and
holding together that International
Coalition to support Ukraine in its in
its Valiant attempt to defend itself on
Russian aggression
um Stephen for labor president zlinski
is obviously meeting the Prime Minister
and spending time with him and the
foreign secretary also meeting the king
we understand that there is going to be
a brief visit with Kirsten which is the
first time the two will have met well I
think it's really important that we
remain United in standing alongside the
people of Ukraine to end this war and I
know that there's been consensus in
Parliament so far we need to make sure
that we move Beyond ad hoc announcements
another long-term session to secure the
future of Ukraine I'm desperate to see
that I know parliamentarians will raise
that later today
that's like oh Michael do you stand
squarely behind the the Prime Minister
the lib Dems in terms of their support
for Ukraine and the amount of money that
the UK is sending to Ukraine we
absolutely do and I think in the
occasions you know we've been in a
position to say oh you should be doing
more you should be doing it faster and
that's the role that the responsible
opposition party can take understand
Britain has been able to take a leading
role in the world stage at this time but
we've been able to take that leading
role because we've maintained the
agreement the consensus beyond the
political parties and you know at a time
when so many of the political influences
in our country at the moment are
nationalists and inward looking being
able to remind the country that actually
we're still a major player in the world
stage that we can be a force for good
when we pull together I think is quite
an important lesson to draw from this
it's Teresa Villas there will be some of
those saying that the the sums that we
are signing into Ukraine and the level
of support that we are given to Ukraine
is is too much I mean when we saw
president's legs arrive at number 10 he
we had the Applause from inside is there
a danger do you think that the
government has been slightly dazzled by
him
yeah it is a huge amount of money at a
time when we would you know public
finances are under strain so this is
difficult but I I think it is remarkable
that we've got this really strong
political consensus and I think that
consensus covers much of the general
public as well it is it is not easy to
do what we're doing but it is the right
thing to do and I'm afraid it will
require more resources before this this
conflict is finally at an end okay we
should also touch on domestic matters we
did have this cabinet reshuffle
yesterday uh what did you make of it do
you think it's actually achieved
anything well I am a particular
Enthusiast about the creation of a
Secretary of State for Science and
Technology this is absolutely crucial
for our future economic success so and I
know it's a priority for the Prime
Minister which is why he wanted that
dedicated new Department in in Whitehall
and that's why also spending on R D and
investment in these kind of projects is
being protected despite the the
difficult fiscal situation we were
talking about earlier as Stephen Morgan
do you agree that it is the right
emphasis that the government should be
looking at this now and the creation of
this kind of department is something
quite forward-looking I think what we
saw yesterday was a prime minister that
just has sticking plaster politics for
our country he's tinkering around the
edges we're moving the deck chairs and
the Titanic sinking and I think what
we've got is a premise who's weak and a
divided party that aren't tackling the
issues that this country faces you talk
about the Titanic there um no no
surprise perhaps that you've brought
that because Lee Anderson who's the new
Tory Vice chair as somebody who said
that the government was like abandoned
the Titanic just a short while ago what
do you make of his appointment well Lee
Lee speaks his mind he's he's a great
guy I wouldn't necessarily agree with
all his statements on every issue but I
know that he's a phenomenal campaigner
and he's absolutely determined to ensure
a conservative Victory next time around
but his appointment is just is the
problem that he is a a campaigner and
he's just been taken onto a swage you
know those who are concerned about
losing seats in the red wall we had one
Northern Tory MP yesterday tell Sam
coats Lee Anderson is everything that's
wrong with the conservative brand
presently I don't believe that is true
for a moment I mean Lee demonstrates a
journey from labor to the conservatives
he is someone who decided he wanted to
change things in his community and and
he decided the best way to do that was
to join the conservatives and now he's
the MP and I think he's doing great work
Titanic Lane just doesn't work because
if you're going to have a band you've
got to have people plague in Harmony and
right at the moment in the cabinet you'd
find you would struggle to find enough
people to play in harmony to bring a
string quartet together that's the root
cause of the problem Rishi sunic has no
Authority and he is trying to lead a
party that is going in different
directions all the time the occasional
assignments for technology department
yeah good worthy thing to do but it's
hardly the radical reboot that this
government needs and the reason is that
he didn't have the political authority
to do the things he did he needed to do
if he did Dominic Ram would not be in a
job this morning the fact that Dominic
ramp stays there shows the weakness of
Rishi sunai because he does not have the
authority to suck him would you like to
have seen Dominic perhaps moved or at
least suspended while this investigation
continues no I think these these
allegations have to be investigated and
once that process is finished then a
decision will will be made but the prime
minister's on his feet I'm going to
pause you all thank you all very much
it is a testament to the unbreakable
friendship between our two countries and
I'm proud that we are expanding the
training for Ukrainian forces to include
jet pilots and Marines and ensure that
Ukraine has a military able to defend
its interest today and into the future
Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today Philip Pogba Slava Ukraine
presidentski We Salute You
this year the start will be made to the
rebuild of Kettering General Hospital
northamptonshire police will reach 1500
police officers the highest number ever
in its history and Kettering is set to
become one of the best connected towns
for ultrafast Broadband in the whole
country thanks to City fiber's
investment together with the prime
minister's pledge to halve inflation and
tackle the NHS backlogs isn't it time to
tackle head-on the Doom and Gloom
peddled by those who want this country
to fail
and to be far more optimistic about the
many good things happening in Kettering
and across the country
well my uh my honorable friend is
absolutely right and I'm glad to hear of
all the successes in his constituency
especially the Redevelopment of
Kettering general hospital or something
I know honorable friend has been camping
campaigning on tirelessly for years but
he's right this government will continue
to focus on delivering the country's
priorities
opposition
thank you Mr Speaker
over 11 000 people have died as a result
of the devastating earthquake in turkey
and Syria and that number is sadly
rising and I know many families here in
the UK will be anxiously awaiting news
I'm sure I speak for the whole house in
saying our hearts go out to each and
every victim and their families and we
must do all we can to support the rescue
and Recovery efforts
Mr Speaker this house is honored to be
addressed today by president zielinski
from the outset of the war
he has symbolized the heroism the
resolve and The Bravery of his people
the Prime Minister and I joined this
house together in 2015. we've lived
through important moments in our
domestic and international politics
but none of those experiences compares
to the pain and suffering of the people
of Ukraine
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that right across this house it is vital
that we all continue to stand together
in full support of Ukraine
prime minister well can I first join
with uh The Honorable member for paying
our respects and thoughts to the people
of turkey and Syria particularly those
affected by the earthquake and the First
Responders who are doing such a valiant
job the house will be reassured to know
that we are in touch with the Turkish
and Syrian authorities and providing all
assistance that they have required of us
including 77 search and rescue
responders that arrived yesterday and
have already begun work and I spoke to
the President yesterday to ensure that
we are in close communication and can I
Thank The Honorable gentleman for his
comments on Ukraine it's something that
not only the whole country can be proud
of but the entire house can be proud
that we came together to stand by
Ukraine when the moment mattered and
that we will continue to stand with them
United as one part Parliament and one
United Kingdom just for the record is
the right honorable Kirsten
thank you Mr Speaker for that answer
because every time Putin has been
appeased he's been back for more and so
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that across this house we must speak
with one voice and say this terrible
conflict must end with the defeat of
Putin in Ukraine
questions
Mr Speaker our objective remains to
ensure a Ukrainian victory in this
conflict Vladimir Putin Vladimir Putin's
aggression cannot be seen in any way to
have been successful and that's why we
have accelerated and increased our
support militarily for Ukraine this
year's the decision that I took as prime
minister today we are going even further
not just having provided Challenger
tanks from being one of the first
countries to do so which catalyze the
provision of tanks from other nations as
well but also today to move to start
training Ukrainian Marines in the
advanced capabilities they will need to
mount further offensive but also to
train their pilots on Advanced combat
aircraft so the house can be reassured
we will continue to support Ukraine to
ensure decisive military Victory on the
battlefield this year
Mr Speaker can I welcome the additional
support the Prime Minister has outlined
today I've had the privilege I'm sure he
has of seeing firsthand the brilliant
work our military is doing in Salisbury
to train ukrainians in defending
themselves we all support this work and
the UK's role in the International Drive
to ensure that Ukraine has the weapons
and the technology required to defend
herself
does the Prime Minister agree that
continuing this International effort is
the only way to ensure Putin's defeat
prime minister
Mr Speaker that the house may not all be
aware that actually we have continued to
train Ukrainian soldiers because it's
something that we have done for years
before the conflict started and
something that we should be very proud
of but obviously we've intensified those
efforts last year we trained 10 000
Ukrainian soldiers through operation
interflex this year the defense
secretary announced that last year we'll
be training 20 000 uh Ukrainian soldiers
in addition to the Marines and Air Force
pilots that I mentioned earlier but the
Rhino gentleman is right to highlight
this has been an international effort
one thing that is a mark of UK
leadership in this particular area is
that around a dozen other countries have
all come here to the Ukraine uh to the
UK to take part in our training programs
to support Ukrainian soldiers many
people many members from around this
house all have visited in their
constituencies that effort it's
something that's making an incredible
difference on the ground and I know
something that the president zielinski
is incredibly grateful for
I think the whole house would like to
thank those is involved in the
incredible training that is going on Mr
Speaker before I entered this house I
had responsibility for fighting for
justice in The Hague for victims of
Serbian aggression
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that when the war in Ukraine is over
Putin and all his cronies must stand at
the Hague and face Justice
[Applause]
Mr Mr Speaker
is absolutely right that we must hold
those to account for the horrific crimes
that they have committed I'm proud that
the United Kingdom has played again a
leadership role in this regard being one
of the first countries to provide
financial and Technical Support putting
investigators on the ground we're surely
to be hosting a conference together with
the Dutch and also one of the things I
discussed with President zelenski this
morning is our support for the work of
the ICC where thanks to the efforts of
UK members I'm hopeful that we will see
the first indictments very shortly
Mr Speaker across this house we don't
just hope for Ukraine's Victory we
believe in it
and part of that Victory must be
Ukraine's reconstruction does the Prime
Minister agree with me that Russia
should pay for the destruction it has
caused through the well-flying dormant
in blocked Russian government assets
prime minister Mr Speaker we are the
third largest humanitarian economic
donor to Ukraine 1.4 billion pounds of
support that we have provided through
direct Grant assistance and guarantees
that multilateral lending organizations
and again the house will remember we
took a lead in imposing economic
sanctions on Russian entities including
individuals and state sanctioned assets
we've ensured the provision of funds
here will be put in a foundation for
reconstruction in Ukraine and we are
currently working with International
Partners through the legal process to
use those assets to fund Ukrainian
reconstruction of course that's
something that we all want to see and
we're working with our partners to
achieve that yeah
thank you Mr Speaker as a country we've
always been at our best when we stand up
to tyrannical aggressors threatening
their neighbors and peace on our
continent
that's why the labor party helped found
NATO and why our commitment to Nato is
as unshakable today as it was back then
does the Prime Minister agree with me
says we may have no matter what
difficulties we face as a country
we in this house have a duty to stand on
the shoulders of giants who came before
us and support Ukraine's Fight For
Freedom Liberty and victory
prime minister Mr Speaker we Remain the
leading European Ally in NATO as we
always have done we continue to increase
funding in our Armed Forces by 24
billion pounds at the last spending
review to ensure that we make maintain
not just our NATO obligation to spend
two percent of our GDP on defense but
also we participate in every NATO
operation and remain the leading Nation
when it comes to contributions to NATO's
rapid response force and the NATO
Readiness initiative but I joined with
the honorable gentleman in saying that
this house and this country Will Stand
United with the with the Ukraine until
we ensure the defeat of Vladimir Putin's
unprovoked unsanctioned aggression and
that we will make sure that Ukraine is
not only Victorious but that we bring
peace to its people
thank you Mr Speaker the global combat
air program including team Tempest is
vital for UK National Security and for
the world-class Aerospace cluster we've
got in Lancashire with many businesses
in Burnley and Patio this aircraft will
protect UK Skies give the orif the tools
it needs for the future and deepen our
relationship with allies like Japan and
Italy so can I ask the prime minister
with a refresh of the integrated review
taking place to commit not just to the
design and development of this aircraft
but to its production in Lancashire too
providing skilled jobs for generations
to come for my constituents and
residents all across the county of
Lancashire
this is because delighted to announce
this Landmark International partnership
with Japan and Italy in December team
Tempest Partners already employed two
and a half thousand people in the UK
with over 1200 in the Northwest and as
we are making more progress we're going
to continue to invest in skills and
Technology at the ba a systems Factory
of the future in Lancashire yeah Stephen
Flynn leader of the SMP
so thank you Mr Speaker and on behalf of
my party I'd like to send our
condolences to all of those impacted by
the devastating earthquake in turkey and
Syria and also to welcome the exchange
between the leader of the opposition and
the prime minister in respect of Ukraine
we all in this house are united in our
condemnation of Vladimir Putin and in
our hope for a better future for Ukraine
it'll be an honor for all of us to
listen to president zielinski this
afternoon
Mr Speaker and in recent days the former
prime minister said that she did not
regret her time in office
does the Prime Minister forget her time
and office
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'd be grateful to all my predecessors
for the contribution that they make to
public life and and what can I join can
I join with the uh join with Ronald
gentlemen in saying that I know the
whole house will be looking forward to
hearing from president zielinski at the
conclusion of pmqs Stephen Flynn Mr
Speaker hold on a minute let's reflect
upon the damage that was caused 30
billion wiped off the UK economy Pension
funds brought to the brink of collapse
the pound-reaching parity with the
dollar and interest rates for mortgage
holders right across these aisles sorry
now the former prime minister won't
apologize for the damage that she has
caused so on behalf of the Tory party
will he apologized for her
prime minister well Mr Speaker On the
first day that I took office I said that
mistakes had been made but what we have
done what we have done what we have done
is to ensure that right now he mentioned
the pound the pound at a multi-month
high borrowing costs restored back to
where they should be
an economy is stabilized a clear and a
clear plan to halve inflation and grow
the economy that's that's what the
conservatives are delivering in
government and we continue to deliver it
as well for the people of Scotland
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker Burley house in my
constituency is bidding to host the
World Eventing championships in 2026.
this event is one of the Pinnacles of
the sport
and if we were successful in our bid it
would provide massive it would provide a
massive boost to the local economy as
well as massive coverage for the UK on
the global scene Burnley has a
formidable track record of success
having previously hosted two World
Championships and six European
championships would my right honorable
friend agree with me that Burley would
make a fantastic venue and would he lend
us his support
well Mr Speaker we are committed on
building all our fantastic track record
of Hosting events like the Commonwealth
Games the women's euros and the Rugby
League World Cup I understand the
relevant UK sporting authorities are
looking at the location and I'm sure
that they'll be considering Burley in my
honorable friends constituency uh in the
near future Ed David Mr Speaker can I
associate my party with the comments
made about the unfolding human tragedy
in turkey and Syria and with the warm
words to welcome our Ally president
zelenski
he will know that this country and this
house has total support for Ukraine's
resistance to Vladimir Putin's illegal
invasion and it is a source of great
pride that the British people have stood
firm United and unwavering in support of
the Brave Heroes of Ukraine
Mr Speaker when President zlensky
addressed this house last year
he asked that we treat Russia as a
terrorist state
since then liberal Democrats have been
urging the government to fulfill that
request
by prescribing the Wagner mercenary
group
they are doing Putin's bidding hang out
atrocities against ukrainians on a daily
basis
so on this symbolic day Mr Speaker will
the Prime Minister finally commit to
prescribing the Wagner group a crucial
part of treating Russia as the Rogue
state that it is
well Mr Mr Speaker we have taken a leave
from the beginning of this conflict in
sanctioning and taking action against
those entities connected with the war
effort in Russia and Beyond with regard
to Evangel group The Honorable Iran or
gentleman will know that we have already
sanctioned the Wagner group in its
entirety as well as taking specific
action against particular leaders as
he'll know with regard to prescriptions
is not something that we routinely
comment on in public but rest assured we
continue to keep all of the
prescriptions that we have under review
Peter Gibson thank you Mr Speaker
22 years ago this month a good friend of
mine died from AIDS had he been tested
for HIV I am confident that with the
medical advances we have made he would
still be alive today
as my right honorable friend will know
this week is HIV testing
and I welcome the government's Ambitions
to end new infections by 2030. can I ask
my right honorable friend to thank the
Terence Higgins trust for their
incredible work
and will he look to extend opt-out HIV
testing to more areas of high prevalence
so that we can help discover more
undiagnosed cases prime minister or can
I thank my honorable friend for his uh
incredibly thoughtful question and
expressed my sympathy to him on the loss
of his friend and join him in paying
tribute to the work of the Terence
Higgin trust as I know the whole house
will also join me in doing they do do
fantastic work and I look forward to
talking to my honorable friend about
what more we can do to spread HIV
testing and prevent more people from
needlessly suffering Dave Dugan
thank you Mr Speaker the UK government's
fiscally illiterate electricity
generator Levy will choke off billions
from future investments in renewable
energy projects the kind of projects
that my Angus constituency excels at
delivering this investment will find its
way to more favorable jurisdictions
putting thousands of green jobs in
Scotland Island under energy transition
at risk so will the Prime Minister
commit to scrapping this environmentally
and economically damaging tax or will he
instead confirm that he and this latest
Chancellor know the price of everything
and the value of nothing
Mr Speaker no I I don't think it's right
that because of a war when energy
companies are making windfall profits
that those profits should go untaxed
that's what our Levy does it's right
that we recover those excess profits
from energy companies as a result of the
war and give that money back to the
country in the form of support with
their energy bills what is economically
uh damaging for Scotland is the smp's
refusal to acknowledge the existence and
need for a transition and that's to
support the naughty oil and gas industry
which we are proud to do
[Music]
Mr Speaker human trafficking is when you
move people legally from one place to
another often with the promise of a job
and then force that person into
prostitutional or labor exploitation it
has nothing to do with people who come
illegally here in small boats that is
smuggling a third of all human
trafficking in the United Kingdom occurs
wholly within the borders of the United
Kingdom when I was chairman of the old
party group against human trafficking we
campaign for an independent commissioner
one was appointed in 2014. however since
April of last year we have not had one
this is unacceptable because would the
Prime Minister use his good offices to
get one appointed urgently prime
minister or can I thank my honorable
friend for all his work in this
important area are happy to look into
the particular position that he mentions
and I know that he is proud as I am of
our world-leading modern slavery
legislation thanks to the former prime
minister on these benches it is a
world-leaning piece of legislation we're
showing so Show an example about how to
tackle this but I'll make sure that we
have someone in place to do the job
thank you Mr Speaker there are now more
than 50 more social Care staff vacancy
than last year people are stuck in
hospital beds with nowhere to go and my
bath constituency the level Democrat
Council and our local hospital the ruh
are trying their level best and trying
new innovative solutions to tackle that
social care backlog but the Prime
Minister knows that this is a Workforce
crisis we must recruit and retain social
Care staff so I asked him will he
support the liberal Democrat proposal to
pay a higher minimum wage to social care
workers to tackle the social care
shortages that underpin the NHS crisis
prime minister well Mr Speaker we
recently announced uh 14 billion pounds
more for Health and Social care and in
particular uh that money part of that
money will go to a new discharge fund to
speed the discharge of people from
hospitals back into their homes and in
their communities that money is already
making a difference on the ground we can
see the numbers of people aren't
necessarily in hospitals are already
reducing easing the burdens in our a e
departments and that comes on top of the
money that we've invested to improve
training Recruitment and development of
our value social Care staff and that
will make sure that we can reduce
vacancy rates increase retention and get
the workforce that we know we need
Bradley
Mr Speaker last month together with
fellow North Staffordshire MPS I hosted
an event a tea party to welcome
Ukrainian refugees living in North
Staffordshire would the Prime Minister
join me in thanking the sponsors in
particular Alton Towers who hosted the
event the host families and all the
people of North Staffordshire who've
made our Ukrainian friends so very
welcome
well I joined my honorable phone in
thanking Alton Towers the other sponsors
and indeed all the families involved in
putting on a tea party I know many
members from across the house uh will
have done something similar It's a
Wonderful way to show our support for
the families that have come here and
again something that the president this
morning mentioned to me how grateful he
is to the United Kingdom that we have
opened up our hearts and our homes to
help those in his country that need our
security and Sanctuary
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker Big Brother watch
recently released a report into
unaccountable government bodies such as
the counter disinformation unit the
rapid response unit and the British
Army's 77 Brigade we're seeing huge
sways of public money being spent
recording political dissent on social
media under the guise of tackling this
information politicians including myself
the leader of the opposition academics
activists and journalists and even
members of public have been subjected to
monitoring by Whitehall officials this
at the same time as they're waiting for
the reporting of the Pitchford inquiry
into questionable state surveillance on
campaigns like the Stephen Lawrence
campaign so can the Prime Minister tell
us how much public money is spent on
these units and whether he thinks
they're justifiable thing to do in our
democracy to spend public money in this
manner and could you also update the
house on the progress of the Pitchford
inquiry prime minister well Mr Speaker I
have to get back to the honorable lady
on the pigeon inquiry and indeed to give
her an exact figure but in general uh I
think certainly I on this side of the
house believe very strongly in free
speech and we'll make sure that we
continue to protect it wherever we can
yeah
to speak up Friday the 24th of February
will mark one year of Russia's barbaric
war in Ukraine thousands of people have
been killed over a thousand children
have been killed or injured so will my
right honor will friend the Prime
Minister call for a national minute of
Silence on that day so that all across
the United Kingdom the people here can
show their unending support for the
people of Ukraine Minister uh well can I
thank my honorable friend for all the
work that she has done in her previous
roles to ensure that we provide
appropriate support to those in Ukraine
I thank her very much for her suggestion
I'm sure it's something that we are
considering as we speak and there will
be many other ways that we can mock that
moment not least as an International
Community continuing to show United
condemnation and isolation of Russia
try to make coffee
this week Mr Speaker is Children's
Mental Health week we know that adverse
childhood experiences whether that be
growing up in poverty in the UK or
indeed living through the horrors of war
in the Ukraine can have a lifelong
impact on Mental Health with a number of
children in Mental Health crisis
increasing year on year in the UK does
the Prime Minister believe he's doing
enough to address the causes of
childhood trauma prime minister can I
Thank The Honorable member for her
question and let her know that we are
doing more to make sure that the extra
money we're putting into tacking mental
health is particularly focused on young
people where we've seen a a very
startling increase in the number of
young people presenting with mental
health conditions that we all would like
to arrest and reduce that's why we're
putting more Mental Health Community
Support into schools and colleges across
the country that's being rolled out as
we speak and also just the other week we
announced more money for crisis centers
and urgent treatment centers in the
mental health space in a hundred
different communities around the country
which will make a difference Richard
Graham Mr Speaker this country is
military and diplomatic support for
Ukraine is strong and has strong support
across the country less well-known is a
program that has gone on for a decade
led by the Westminster foundation for
democracy to support the verkoff Narada
or Ukrainian pun so does my right
honorable friend agree that should this
country host a reconstruction conference
with the ukrainians to discuss how
Ukraine can win the peace that the
foreign office and the Westminster
foundation and other bodies can come
together to see how we can help
president zielinski in the next stage of
his country's development prime minister
my honorable friend makes an excellent
point and as we look forward to hosting
the Reconstruction conference for
Ukraine later this year I'll make sure
to take off this suggestion and involve
all those organizations that can provide
support to us and ultimately make sure
that we can rebuild Ukraine in the way
that it deserves religion Ford
thank you Mr Speaker the government will
want to help maintain popular backing in
the UK for our support to Ukraine
including by helping people with their
energy bills more than 40 000 people
across Devon live in homes that are off
the gas grid they're on the rural
equivalent of prepayment meters they
need the money up front in order to pay
for their heating oil and for their
alternative fuels the government
announced an alternative fuel payment
last September but people in Devon are
still waiting what will the Prime
Minister say to people who are off the
gas grid and are waiting for their
alternative fuel payment five months
later
well Mr Speaker we specifically
considered people who are off the gas
grid when designing the energy support
schemes that we put in place which is
why the bulk of the support was
delivered to those who had electricity
meters to ensure it reached people like
you mentioned including many of my own
rural constituents as well that money
should be getting to them I'll make sure
that it moves as quickly as possible but
we also put in place the local household
support fund to provide discretionary
funding that local councils can give to
those households who are most innocent
speaker there's no doubt that the NHS is
under enormous pressure across the UK
and despite record numbers of nurses and
doctors Workforce remains to China so
can I welcome it for the first time the
NHS will get independently verified
Workforce plan but we have to think long
term on buildings too and so in that
regard can the Prime Minister look
closely at proposals to rebuild Leighton
Hospital which is a campaign that has a
spot of thousands of residents in the
South Cheshire
prime minister
well Mr Speaker I I uh I know that late
in hospital has been allocated over 44
million pounds to address some of the
immediate issues at that site but I also
know that the honorable friend is Keen
to ensure continued investment in his
local hospital and I know that the
department for health are looking at
more hospitals to join the new hospital
program and I'm sure that they will have
heard what he said indeed the voices of
his constituents too let's twist Mr
Speaker bus services our Vital trial
communities for work for health for
school and for socializing but in a
matter of days the buses that Millions
depend on will face another crisis with
the ending of the bus recovery Grant and
predicted cuts of 15 to 20 in mileage
would be devastating for people across
my constituency and others will the
Prime Minister commit to extending the
bus recovery Grant so that communities
in my constituency and many others are
not left isolated and will he ask the
transport secretary to meet with me to
discuss this issue
prime minister oh Mr Speaker we
recognize the vital importance of buses
in our local communities and that's why
we're well on the way to fulfilling our
commitment to invest three billion
pounds over this parliament in our bus
transformation and that includes funding
for local councils to subsidize on
profitable routes through the bus
services operators Grant and recent
money to help cap operate Affairs at two
pounds through the spring and of course
we always continue to see how we can
support bus services in the long term
Mr Speaker would my right honorable
friend agree that apprenticeships such
as those offered by the excellent South
Essex College in Leon sea which I
visited on Monday for National
apprenticeship week are a great pathway
into work
yeah well Mr Speaker I completely agree
uh with my honorable friend to pay
tribute to her local College
particularly in National apprenticeship
for a week and I know something that we
discussed just in cabinet yesterday uh
we also have the the country's first
education secretary who herself was an
apprentice and it's something we're
proud of
what
because Mr Speaker can I join the Prime
Minister and the leader of the
opposition in their condolences to the
victims of the devastating earthquake in
turkey and Syria can I also reiterate my
thanks to the foreign secretary and for
the speed of the initial UK response Mr
Speaker but as we enter the third day of
the of of the earthquake the bitter cold
Unforgiven weather means that the
likelihood of pulling more survivors
from the rubble becomes less and less
likely and the immediate humanitarian
impact is devastating so can I ask the
Prime Minister when we can expect an
announcement on what further Aid he's
government will commit to relief efforts
and what discussions he is having with
his International counterparts to ensure
our response meets the scale of this
crisis prime minister can I Thank The
Honorable lady for her question and join
her and paying tribute to the foreign
secretary for the work that he's doing
so I spoke to President erdogan
yesterday to reiterate our commitment to
provide turkey with what support they
need right now that is search and rescue
she's right we are in that vital window
at the beginning of a situation like
this which is why our search and rescue
teams are on the ground providing that
assistance the front secretary is also
speaking to his counterpart of the
United Nations to ensure that the
humanitarian support that we can provide
is well targeted also in Syria where we
fund the white helmets which are on the
ground doing work we're continuing to be
in touch with everyone that we need to
and I can assure The Honorable lady will
continue to supply provide all the
support that is asked of us
I'm pleased to announce as members will
be aware that President zielinski will
be addressing both houses in Westminster
Hall imminently that will require me to
suspend The house's business in a moment
members attending the address should go
directly to the hall following the
doorkeeper's directions
the house is expected to resume its
sitting at approximately two o'clock the
division's bells will be sounded five
minutes before the resumption the house
is now suspended order order
well the end of prime minister's
questions and the suspension of the
House of Commons in order to listen to
president zielinski speech he's not due
to speaker about half an hour actually
but our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates is here we'll talk about the
rather unusual pmqs in a moment but
let's bring you some pictures that we've
just had in uh video uh from the social
media account of President zelenski's
interior Minister this shows the initial
greeting between him and the Prime
Minister after he landed at Stansted
Airport uh warm hugs coming off that RAF
jet we know that they then traveled by
car together to Downing Street
where they also had the obligatory
handshake
outside the famous door before heading
in to discuss British support for
Ukraine
well once aside at number 10 we could
hear the Applause from the staff who
were inside and the millions had a few
words in front of the fireplace talking
about the support that the UK has given
Ukraine
Advance freedom for society
first world for your big support
from the first days of full scale in
baseball thank you so much we are proud
really and we have very good
relationships we appreciate and we'll
prolong our dialogue which will I think
very important very important for
security while 100 of course the
security for for the walls
they're then headed off separately to
Parliament with President zielinski
leaving first ahead of his speech at one
o'clock in around half an hour's time
and then the Prime Minister left to go
to Prime Minister's questions which
you've just seen and our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates has been
watching it with me here in the studio
and Sam one main story that they all
talked about Ukraine all of kirstalma's
questions about Ukraine pretty much what
did you make of it
so I I thought you got the best sense
that Politics as normal have been
suspended today uh we weren't expecting
we didn't have any advanced notice that
the visit from president zelinski was
going to take place this morning we
didn't know one was on the cards and yet
it is completely dominated the news
agenda uh really there are going to be
only two stories all the way through the
day on the news and one is what's
happening in turkey and Syria and the
other is uh the visit by president
zielinski now at moment of kind of where
the world Spotlight sort of the domestic
Spotlight and the world is looking at
the UK Parliament at the House of
Commons it it can feel that people rise
to the occasion
today was a lot of people just getting
in on the ACT I'm afraid if I'm being
completely brutal
um there were lots of people making lots
of points I'm not sure that we learned
anything I'm not sure that that we shed
much light
um on on anything uh what you did have
was a sense that everybody was on the
same page uh there were no dissenting
voices when it comes to Britain standing
steadfast uh with its Ukrainian allies
and although president zielinski wasn't
in the viewing Gallery as perhaps he
might have might have been he's
preparing for that one o'clock statement
in Westminster Hall which is
a few meters away uh to both houses of
Parliament uh you didn't get any any
sign of dissent and uh the opposition
labor party under kirstama made it quite
clear that they would uh be standing
taking pretty much the same position
that Rishi sunak has has done uh which
is the same positions list same position
uh as um Boris Johnson
um but then beyond that it was a it was
a session that's that basically saw a
lot of people trying to come up with new
angles sort of on the on the same you
know on this on the same thing and and
and and and gently trying to underscore
their own domestic political position
um if you look at que estarma's
calculation tonight
um I think that he decided he will have
decided that he wanted to use all of his
six question allocation on this because
one of the goals I think at the moment
for the labor leadership is to
underscore their hope that people start
to see kirstama not just as a domestic
figure but as a global Statesman and
that was one of the things behind that
trip at the end of January to Davos so
you could see kiss Dumber on the world
stage
uh hanging out with fellow global
leaders even though he's a he's an
opposition party figure and I think that
by being able to
effectively concentrate today just on
this one Global International Affairs
international relations topic he he
looks he he looks to to do that again
um uh they hope that that has some
beneficial effect and also cynically uh
there isn't going to be anything else on
the news all the way through the day so
there's no point in making party
political uh attacks they'd seem to fall
on deaf ears um when uh when the other
leaders and the other MPS and pmqs uh
made them but then but then he sort of
danced around the houses he wanted to
underscore uh Labor's commitment to Nato
that's sort of making a domestic
political Point
um uh he he also talked about uh what
victory will rather defeat for President
Putin would look like and and here I
think you get quite quickly into the
into the to a gray and uncomfortable
area not that anyone really actually
wanted to debate the difficult bits of
the Ukraine crisis in the Commons
chamber today because he asked um uh uh
do we have to keep going until President
Putin accepts defeat given that
President Putin keeps on coming back for
more but but in asking that question he
sort of highlighted that it's it's
unclear what victory looks like does it
involve President Putin still being in
office or if as Kirsten argues he is
Dylan office won't he come back for more
but of course uh president Pete and
staying in office in Moscow is not a
subject that I think that UK politicians
would want to pronounce on and make that
a hurdle uh for victory or a goal
because of the possible uh incendiary
consequences that that kind of position
uh would have
um similarly talking about things like
reparations having to fall to Russia for
what's happened happened in in Ukraine
is sort of dancing around and a a sort
of area that's that's theoretical but
sounds good to the average punters the
average uh to the average
um voter so I think that there was uh
and then by the time we got to Vicki
Ford dressed in Ukrainian is asking
whether or not there's been a minute
silence for Ukraine I think that that
rather summed up I thought that some of
the tone of bits of bits of today
um uh so in a situation where the House
of Commons is United I don't think that
we learned a great deal other than
sending a strong signal of support in of
itself important ahead of President
zielinski's uh uh address but not one
where politicians particularly stepped
to stepped up and took us uh uh uh
beyond the kind of the basics of what we
already know
Sam thanks very much